foreign
welcome back to another episode of the
ADI hour it's my pleasure to continue to
host these conversations I've definitely
been appreciative of the engagement of
all of you as listeners and today I'm
very excited to be able to host a
conversation on Justice activism and the
church with Reverend Dr Otis Moss III Dr
Moss thanks so much for being here on
the iar podcast it is my pleasure thank
you for having me of course and we have
had the opportunity to interact
previously Dr Moss and I were part of a
provocative panel back in September of
22 entitled is Christianity bad for your
mental health so you can just imagine
some of the conversations that came up
there but really excited to be able to
interact again in this way
and just by way of introduction for
those who may not be familiar with Dr
Moss want to just let you know that he
is a senior pastor of Trinity United
Church of Christ in Chicago Illinois he
is a preacher an activist and an author
and also over the last two decades he's
someone who has practiced and preached a
black theology that unapologetically
calls attentions to the problems of mass
incarceration environmental justice and
economic inequality
he is a native of Cleveland Ohio an
honors graduate of Morehouse College he
also has a masters of divinity from the
Yale Divinity School so home turf in a
sense for me and a doctorate of ministry
from Chicago Theological Seminary he is
currently a professor at the McAfee
School of Theology At Mercer University
and he is someone who is a third
generation Warrior for civil and human
rights he's committed to preaching a
prophetic message of love and Justice
which he believes are inseparable
companions that form the foundation of
the Gospel of Jesus Christ
I should also mention this is a legacy
for him both personally and in terms of
his family he's been heavily influenced
and has a foundation from his father Dr
Otis Moss Jr and also from Dr Martin
Luther King Jr whom his father worked
with at one point as well so again just
to give you all just a little bit of
insight I know we'll hear more but just
appreciate the work that you continue to
do and you're willingness to be here for
this podcast conversation thank you I'm
honored
excellent and as my listeners know one
of the benefits of these conversations
is we have a lot of guests who are just
generous with their openness and being
willing to peel back the layers as it
were so I want to just do a check-in and
see how you're doing at this point in
time with everything that we're
experienced as a society and especially
soberingly with just all the challenges
around gun violence both the mass
shootings that seem to be happening on a
weekly basis and all the other gun
violence that does not get that same
national attention so just if you're
wanting to share how you're doing at
this point yeah I appreciate that
um right now I am I use the word okay
when you say the scale of 1 to 10 that
usually means like five
so in the middle
um
I I received a call and that one of our
our deacons actually
found his younger brother who had uh
committed suicide by by hanging
unfortunately oh wow and he found the
body and oh my goodness just a uh just
devastating and right before getting on
this podcast
one of our members just just sent us a
text that uh
she went to the hospital to see her
father she her father was was was at
Assisted Living place but they never
called her to share that he was being
transferred to the hospital she gets to
the hospital no one had called her
noticed anything and her father's gone
wow and uh you know just uh you know the
weight of you know those two two people
that walk in with them
uh as they are preparing
for for homegoings uh books and
one
that's what I said one
who had lived a beautiful long life and
and then one where uh you know you have
a family that's with as it is with with
suicide uh you raise questions and
trying to walk with the family and let
them know that uh this is not punishment
your your loved one is loved by God and
God's arm all of that without all of the
noise and trash
that seep into our subconscious because
we have such
horrific uh
pastoral care and just bad Theology and
just add public Civic conversation
about people who just really are looking
for individuals to to to support them
and to walk with them and love them
in the black churches yeah trying to you
know to walk with people in in their
most vulnerable performance yeah well
definitely appreciate your level of
honesty just in talking about where you
are at this point in time and I know
that a lot of listeners you know
especially those who have experience or
in the black church can relate to that
piece as well but some listeners might
also even feel surprised to hear you say
that you're the five with that level of
heaviness that you often have to walk
through
um but you know you touched on so many
important pieces in terms of meeting
people where they're at but then just
all the noise that can come as well um
just just to maybe even peel back a
little bit more even before we jump into
some of the other topics how do you as a
pastor and a faith leader navigate that
for those that you are ministering to
with all the noise trying to help them
navigate but then also trying to make
sure that it's framed in the right way
both for them for their families for the
church for society I know that's a very
large question but
just curious anything I think on a
personal level it is important that you
are
grounded in community in your own
Community I'm not talking about
quote-unquote just the church Community
because for those who are pastors you're
probably listening to the the most
difficult thing is pastors need to be
pastored pastors need to community in
which they are uh nurtured and cared so
that they can be good caregivers
especially during moments of
vulnerability uh and Challenge and so
being in a community there's your family
and then there are people that are
around you that uh support you so that's
that's one of of the things and then
having the appropriate spiritual
practices for for yourself
um you know the time of Silence you know
mindfulness prayer uh music for me has
always been very helpful
um and as a spiritual practice
listening to and spending time just
listening to music that puts you in a
particular place and reading uh reading
scripture
uh I'm going through a book right now uh
called the uh the teaching of Christian
Mystics uh effectively and so what I do
is I read out loud
um because reading out loud changes
things number one number two
most of what we read that is ancient was
never meant to be read in your head this
is oral transmission
so why do we become so modern and say
read this in my head but when you read
uh out loud all of a sudden the the
phrasing the the the voice uh the pause
catches you in a different way than when
you read something in your head
um I mean I I'm encouraging I teach and
I encourage my students to say before
you even
um go to a scripture and you're going to
start trying to work on a sermon I want
you to read it out loud and read it out
loud in five different translations wow
you know and and watch what happens just
by reading you're not trying to
Force anything or just just read it and
it becomes a great meditative process
and uh discipline to read
out loud and to read because
for example I'm sorry I'm talking so
long it sounds good but like if you say
the Lord is my shepherd
or do you say the Lord
is
my shepherd or do you say the Lord is my
shepherd
no all the exact same words
but based on the the usage of your voice
a different meaning comes comes forth
and different emotion is is presented
that's why reading out loud
reading poetry out loud
um reading scripture out loud and
that's why we sing songs out loud
yeah like songs in my head no you
started reading it started singing it
yeah I mean it's it's one thing to to
say it in your in your head but out you
know singing out thinking you know
becomes a powerful a powerful art form
well that's so powerful and so good I
know people are listening to that and
even just reflecting I mean even that
simple phrase that you are in three
different ways just the power that comes
from that and then you I mean you also
talked about community and maybe we're
getting off script here too but how do
you see those two pieces going together
especially as a pastor I mean with
things that happen
you know we're not just in our
congregations but in the world and as we
navigate them as communities
I think Community is necessary for uh
for human flourishing we're we're
designed as Community creatures you know
we were created in in community
to be in community Genesis talks about
uh Humanity being alone it's not good to
be alone there are times you need to be
alone
um but we we're we we learn in community
we are nurtured in community
we develop developing community and when
we experience trauma we come out of
trauma
or learn how to navigate trauma
through healthy community
and without a healthy Community it's not
you are not able to flourish as as a
human being and you're not able to to
reach your your full potential
you need to be in a in a healthy in a
healthy community and when families are
unhealthy families are Community uh it
it takes a toll on on your soul
and you have to place yourself in in a
space where you can be in and around
healthy people and that's one of the
aspects of of the black church and say
the black church specifically
that
they're in a church there are multiple
communities
and when you find the space of
the appropriate Community an
intergenerational community of Elders
and younger people people who are
middle-aged some who are who are who are
married and some who are not and you
have this potpourri of people
in your garden
are providing
aspects for for human development and
you know it's kind of like just like a
regular Garden you know some people like
basil uh some people are like mint
you know you know some people are like
rose bushes but got a whole a whole lot
of thorns you know so you know you and
you you have to know that they're not
all the same and you and and together
uh they they give all of the necessary
nutrients spirit for a person to to
truly flourish that's so wonderfully
here and you know my listeners have
heard me talk about community and lots
of different settings often bringing up
just the biology of what that does in
our brains and the social binds so it's
so nice to hear from a holistic
perspective just to hear you actually
emphasize and talk about Community
within the church how important that is
for our soul and all these different
pieces together
um and how that really helps us navigate
and even as we've talked about things
like traumas as you hint to that and how
people walk through that together as a
community and just the ways that God has
designed us to be in community the ways
we can see that show up in our
biological changes the way we can see
that in psychological processes the way
we can see that on a global scale and
again it just seems in so many ways at
the heart of what you are doing in your
roles even as I think about what you've
talked about in terms of mental health
but also some of the social justice work
thinking about criminal injustices just
the activism and the family history that
you have of how does that aspect of
community for you what does that
actually look like across all of these
different spectrums because again people
you know might be hearing about and
saying well you're touching on so many
different components and how do you tie
those all together
that's an interesting question
um
how do we tie them all together well for
for me I was was raised in a space
that
believe that the the black community
is varied
and diverse
and it is also your responsibility not
only to be a part of
but to ensure that this community is
thriving
um
uh so be a part and and thriving so
there's you know there's kind of the the
church you know Community there's
um what I would call like for those
who've gone to hbcus you know there's
another community that develops the
result of that if you went to a pwi uh
you've created your own little community
in on on on that level been there the
community that you have at your your
work then there's the family community
then there's the community of friends uh
friends that you've developed
as a child
grew up with friends that you have
connected with
uh during your adulting process which is
some is called college or if you're you
know you're an apprentice program or
whatever it may be or military
and then there are friends that develop
as a result of common trauma and tragedy
that the developing relationships with
and and then there are the people that
you a person that you choose to be your
life partner
that I would hope would be a bit would
be your best friend you know that you
should go down that uh down that down
that road
all of those
communities
make the fullness of who are
and all of those communities
um
have their uh uh
North Star and also have moments where
the the stars are obscured and they get
off course all of those communities
that's that's just the part if you dare
to claim to be human and you seek to
live your call you will you will deal
with those those issues but all these
aspects of community though uh make up
who you are and make up
who who are we see as our wider
Community
um and I'm you know speaking you know
from from the perspective of someone who
is out of the African-American community
and there's some very unique aspects to
our community I mean just like
Barbershop Community you know you know I
mean that I like going to the barbershop
and that community of people usually
Brothers especially when they you know
start arguing about sports and and start
lying about other stuff there's
something that's that's very endearing
yeah about being in that space and
there's something stress relieving about
being in that space as someone you know
they're cutting your hair you know you
get the hook up you know with with the
cut and whatnot and you get to you know
to argue or hear a whole bunch of
ridiculous theories about the world yeah
uh there's no other space where people
get a chance to
um
communicate uh lie promote uh
it's all there is everybody it's
everything in in those spaces
um you know it's it's similar to when
you know people gather together and they
play spades or something that nature you
you have that that level of energy
sometimes you know you know uh come spot
yeah and some surprise surprises there
aren't surprises in terms of the things
that come out of people's mouths but
it's healthy too yeah yeah it is it's
fascinating it's just it's it's the best
comedy in the world in is in the
barbershop because you have some of the
best storytellers and they're explaining
stories yeah that are absolutely not
true and everybody knows it but we still
want to hear the story
no matter what because they're such a
good Storyteller yeah yeah I mean even
not to make it too academic all of a
sudden but I know there's a lot of
initiatives just even using that space
and all the benefits of it yeah to
actually help people open up about
mental health challenges because that's
a lot of that's the first point of
contact for a lot of people so that be
able to be equipped in that way to
notice something to touch on it and the
space where it's already that sense of
community has been really important in a
lot of communities just for really
pushing that conversation forward yeah
Chicago we have a couple members here
who were part of uh Public Health
initiatives
um where they were using the barber shop
for the Public Health Initiative for you
know people getting checked getting
tested all of that but also for mental
health check-in and now there is an
initiative around uh Barbershop books
replacing in barber shops books for
young people they can take them you know
there's there's no cost to them you know
they said hey you can take it you just
kind of like read and return
uh and so there's been this new movement
around
literacy in connection to barber shops
literacy and mental health I think also
go directly together
you give people spaces where they are
able to to read and to imagine and to
rethink and to see themselves in spaces
that they never would normally
think of themselves and that's one of
the hours I think of afrofuturism yeah
the the idea of seeing black people in a
variety of ways not
uh I wrote an article years ago it's
called the documentary the documentary
impulse in Black film
and you know it's kind of like what's
this article what is this about and I
started reading it's like oh I get it
the writer was saying that for everybody
else
when we write something or something is
presented we get to say it's fiction
but for black people no matter even if
it's just the run-of-the-mill it's like
oh yeah this is really like a
documentary because this is the way
black people are we don't even get to
play
um we don't even get fantasized because
we're always told no it has to be real
uh and that's the beauty of afrofuturism
is that it allows us to to expand our
imagination and one of the most
dangerous things is to have a colonized
imagination that that limits your
ability to be yeah uh witness what you
can be or what your community can be
yeah well that's so so important I'm
glad you're bringing that up and this
reminds me of a lot of the work that
you're already doing just in terms of
Astral futurism but then also the power
of community to change narratives I mean
as you're talking about with literacy as
with mental health
um and I know you as a church have done
a lot of work around that even from
individuals who are formally
incarcerated and how you've been
changing the narrative there as well so
I'd be curious if you just be willing to
talk about about that a little bit for
our listeners to know so hear about some
of those Innovative things that you're
doing to really shift perspective
expectation
um and opportunity
well one of the things that that we we
well let me just begin this way that
there are three pillars to any type of
Community Development work we we do here
at Trinity we've done a lot of Community
Development work and I'll explain a
little bit more about Community
Development work but the three pillars
are Economic Development uh that in
other words our community must benefit
the second pillar is that it must be
sustainable it must be it must be green
um and uh and so there must be some
sustainability must be a green
initiative and then the third pillar is
it must disrupt the mass incarceration
system so so it has to have those
reasons though we've got to benefit from
it it's got to be green and it's got to
disrupt so I like to say that it it's
got to be it's got to be blessed by
black folk and black folk got to be
blessed by it it's got to be green uh in
terms of things that are going to flow
into our pockets into our bank
and it's also got to bind the wounds of
the blood been shed as a result of of
mass incarceration so I'd like to say
it's it's it's red black and green you
know to borrow from Marcus Garvey
um but what we did uh one of our first
initiatives we renovated our church and
we renovated the church
greenstone we want to make a lead
certified building
in doing that we said one the
contractors must be black two those
working on this building must be people
who come from the mass incarceration
system three it has to be green
and this was
kind of a challenge because
most
people who were bidding and things like
that we've never done this before work
with us this is the way it works we we
are the primary contract you're a
subcontractor so this is the way we're
gonna do this
um and so we we created and and built a
re you know renovated our church in that
manner then at one of our next projects
there is a library literally down the
street walking distance from our church
has the largest collection of
African-American literature in the
midwest it's called The Carter G Woodson
Library the Vivian harsh collection I
mean they have letters of Dubois sent to
people in in Chicago I mean it's primary
resources if you're doing your PhD at
University of Chicago University of
Illinois DePaul you have to use this
library but it's in the hood it's it's
in our Hood yeah great Hood by the way
um and so the building had scaffolding
around it not because the city was doing
work but the original contractor did a
poor job and they were worried that the
bricks were going to fall on the heads
of people walking into the library wow
and the scaffolding had been out there
20 years so people got used to it wow
Community Development Corporation just
raised the questions like why is there
scaffolding outside of the building
knowing to raise the question it's like
well that's when we found the story wow
and we organized with the community when
I say organized with Community other
Community Partners other organizations
block clubs you name it and we found out
that the library is heavily used people
love it but is falling apart so we were
going to the city and saying hey we want
you to to renovate the library
and we already did our research there
were five other libraries that were
either built new from the ground up or
renovated uh million dollar Renovations
like 5 10 15 and 20 million dollar
Renovations wow and they came back to us
they said oh we don't have the money I
said well you had the money in every
white yeah
but she didn't have the money in the
black neighborhood so after this initial
meeting uh at the very end of the
meeting I just simply asked one question
I said when's your next Library meeting
the library commission meeting and like
oh they meet once a month on like it was
Wednesday I think and I said thank you
very much and uh don't be nice to them
what I did was I the next Sunday I got
up in the pulpit and I shared with the
congregation you know what happened and
I said there's a library commission
meeting coming up on said date
we'd love it if you would would show up
to express the importance of a library
in the community
now one must understand
that Library commission meetings nobody
goes to unless you're into the Dewey
Decimal System no one goes to a library
commission meeting so on this Library
commission meeting with your perfunctory
they're boring you know they go on for
all about 50 minutes and they you know
they go away they said hey you know
we're going to hire under the librarian
or something and this Library commission
meeting
all of these black people show up come
here I mean and everybody has the same
question I wasn't at the meeting
um they're asking us so you built five
of the libraries but you don't have the
money for for the Carter G Woodson
please let that name sit
named after one of the greatest
historian intellectuals the reason that
we have Black History Month a black
history week that was started by Carter
G Woodson
um you know the miseducation of the
Negro Carnegie Wilson
and so the the meeting ended it like
let's say 7 59 I think it was I got a
call at 801. wow and they were saying
can we meet you know as soon as possible
I was like or be more than happy to meet
with you and so our team met with the
the library commission and they walk in
they were smiling and they said we want
you to know we found 10 million dollars
we got a 10 million dollar gross that's
quick that was quick
he built a library to to renovate the
library I was like oh that's that's
that's really wonderful so I want you to
know that all of your your concerns have
been taken care of but we said no
I said first of all would black people
benefit from it who will be the
contractors second thing is will it be a
green design third will you use brothers
and sisters from the mass incarceration
systems
and they looked dumbfounded and said
well there's there's no policy to to do
that we've never done anything like that
before that that would cost a lot that
wouldn't increase you know they're just
using cost as an isn't it yeah and so we
just said back to them they said our
church did it said if a church that
doesn't have the budget of a city cities
have billions of dollars is able to do
this
why can't the city long story short they
ended up using the same principles that
we used and I would invite anyone who
comes to Chicago to see this Crown Jewel
library now the card Woodson library is
astonishing it is one of the only
libraries in the city of Chicago that
specializes
in Alzheimer's and Dementia so if you're
Giver you can go to this Library they
have a studio in this Library they have
an amazing children's section in this
Library there is an auditorium in this
Library you can have shows and it's like
it is truly a Crown Jewel and on top of
that you have the largest collection of
in American literature in the Midwest
and smack dab on in the heart of the
South Side in the community
and and that's part of the kind of
development
when I say Community Development um
is putting making sure that there is an
institution uh that everyone can utilize
and the library is is one of those
spaces that nobody argues about and you
don't you don't have well well down in
Florida they're arguing about what's in
the library yeah the story
um but usually libraries are the one
community space that just about
everybody can agree on that we want to
make sure that it's functioning well
wow that's I mean just transformative in
so many ways and just to know that you
all held your ground I mean there was a
lot of uh wisdom in that negotiation
process that we call it but just showing
the importance of community as well I
mean you touched on sustainability how
has that played out both in the library
and then what you all are doing just in
the community in general oh it's been
been awesome so the the next phase for
the Community Development Corporation
they started purchasing homes in the
neighborhood that were on the
um what you would call the part of the
Cook County Land Bank they
uh tax delinquent homes and you may get
a home for ten thousand I mean they're
falling apart ten thousand fifteen
thousand dollars and we had a
um developer uh who was part of the
church
and he wanted to develop the homes so
that they would look like
um they did in the suburbs
high-end high-end high-end uh
development but we would not sell them
and anywhere at the cost that they win
uh uh valued at and there was a reason
so let's say with the renovation they
take we get a home 5 10 15 30 000
whatever it may be and after everything
is done it's valued at say 175 um
we sell it at 110 105.
or 95. why because you walk in with
Equity so the moment you buy your home
you walk in with equity and all of the
kind of an internal appointments uh of
the home you know the the kitchen the
the lighting um you know the whole nine
uh the way that the heating and air and
cooling system is done would be on the
same level if you drove to one of the
well-off suburbs so using the same
framing so when the down to a downturn
happens you know you you've got equity
in your home and if you need because one
of the ways that that black people make
money in terms of wealth past wealth is
we've really done that you know through
home ownership so you've already walking
in you've got 25 75
000 worth of equity that's only going to
increase
in 15 20 years then you pass it on to
your children and it does not become a
burden it becomes an asset so we're
talking about you know the idea of
wealth building so we started purchasing
these homes and and then something else
happened which we're dealing with now
then speculators these companies
saw what we were doing and they started
grabbing
the homes on the uh tax delinquent roles
on the land bank oh my goodness
and then trying to sell them without not
even close to any kind of really I mean
they're still falling apart trying to
sell them at a higher price or trying to
sell them to us
oh yeah we'll give it to you um for 80
000. tell me this thing was on the rolls
for 10. all right this it's not livable
you can't live in this home it's falling
apart and and so we see how capitalism
ends up trying to undermine
uh our community when these speculators
come in and they're basically just
trying to you know make a buck and we
found out that all these companies all
these individuals not a single one of
them
lives in the city of Chicago wow
wow
that was the one I mean that was one of
the questions I was going to ask it just
not I was gonna ask about pushback but
this is I mean that's a whole other
level of just
here we have we're doing community
rebuilding we're doing what we're
supposed to do we're doing the work and
then you have people literally outside
of the community so I'm just going to
make a profit of this working class this
middle class community in in Chicago
because there's not going to be anybody
that's going to be you know thick it for
them uh they got another thing coming
but yeah how do you maintain your uh
your hope and your your ability to not
be jaded because I'm hearing you say
this for the first time and all sorts of
reactions
are coming up inside me I'm just
imagining how you navigate that as layer
and how you keep people encouraged in
the midst of that you know um handle
this sounds funny but uh I'm not trying
to be funny but I'm black I mean I mean
it's not true I mean
I'm a lover of history and I and I I'm
I'm a history nerd I'm black history
nerd I'm just a nerd in general
um but especially history nerd and it's
a good thing when I when I when I when I
read it is it is nothing wrong you know
nerds rule the world
right now
um but when I read
stories of
of of Harriet Tubman
of Robert Smalls
well I don't have the right could you
imagine Harriet Tubman saying no I'm
feeling kind of jaded I you know you
know I I only got 300 out like you've
got you know what you just did you know
you you were not only a spy but you were
also you're going back and you're
pulling these out of misery and
emancipating them spiritually I always
think that our ancestors are saying to
us
you know Otis you have all these
resources and communities that you can
connect with and people you have what
your ancestors never had
and you don't have the right
to be cynical mm-hmm you have the right
you can get mad either right you can get
ticked off and you can say the system is
rigged
but but you don't you
all that the being black is is an act of
Hope being black is is is an act of
resistance
being black in this country means that
you are from the descendants of people
who refused
to to give in to Despair and said I
shall rise up again and that's one of
the beautiful things about the black
church the black church is not the white
church and you know black face you know
we have our own theology we have a
theology that says
that speaks about you know you know I I
don't know
um you know when but I know it shall we
we have this it might not come when you
want him and this was these were these
acts of resistance we always place it in
this kind of ephemeral frame of of black
people just you know some type of opioid
or something of that nature for the
masses borrowing from from this you know
this marxian idea but in reality we were
we were in the midst of absurdity and uh
tragedy we were we were framing creating
the scaffolding for hope
and that hope was not something that was
out there
The Hope was that I am a child of God
that the Hope was that I have the
ability that's what Frederick Douglass
did he said this was the most articulate
orator in the history of America
who never went to school
because he he recognized there was one
simple kernel that Albert Thurman says
he said the moment that enslaved black
people recognized
that they were loved
and they were loved by something greater
than what was before them
then resistance
resilience and revolution
was always a part of their spirit
so all said I mean just that perspective
I appreciate you just highlighting that
in so many ways I mean in a lot of ways
it's just something that we need to talk
about more and more and more because
it's not we don't all have the Charles G
with the Carter G Woodson Library
unfortunately that needs to be
replicated
a Woodson Library really every Community
does it's a great Library yeah I mean
have there been conversations I know you
all are focused on you know the work in
the South Side Chicago conversations on
ways to
expand this to other areas or help
replicate I mean just with colleagues
that you have in other locations we've
been even talking about you know maybe
the possibility of doing a uh a
conference because we it's not just the
Woodson Library we have 27 Acres that we
purchased and we are developing that and
that will be already has a medical
center on the property we're now doing
the housing next
uh it will eventually have an urban farm
a five acre farm and it'll have a hotel
uh that we're trying to do using the
same three principles again
Black Folk got a benefit um how to be
sustainable and those who are you've got
to disrupt the mass incarceration system
those three principles always have to be
used in the development and we're going
to have a healing Garden in parts of
nature conservancy and so it'll be over
the next 10 to 50 it's going to take a
while to finish it but we've got phase
one which was a and then we're not
talking about a free clinic we're
talking about Primary Care medical
facility and and get this this always
trips people out uh it's run by black
women you know it's brilliant uh for
brilliant and I say it again brilliant
doctors who run this facility and the
facility is uh through the largest
health care provider in Illinois
Advocate Health Care wow and so we we
developed a land they partner with us uh
and and built a facility and it's and
it's a it's a state-of-the-art medical
center again
in the heart of the south side it's not
you know the the you know there's
nothing wrong with the free clinics I'm
not not throwing shade there but when we
think about our community we're thinking
about something that is uh
a federally subsidized
uh Clinic that is not doing primary care
but it's also doing you know care for
you know for people obviously who don't
have access but this is also practicing
preventive care
nurses into the community
to let them know hey you know um can I
come by your uh big West meeting and let
me let me let me show you
um it signs for a stroke you know
because most time we end up going into
the emergency room for our health care
instead we're in the preventive work so
the medical center is is working on
preventive care which is really exciting
so we're trying to create a model what
does
what's the model from Cradle to the
Grave if you want to create a community
what do you need to do and you know
church is kind of the heart uh the the
library is another anchor right in our
community which is right down the street
and then a mile down you have this 20 27
Acres that is next door
to Chicago State University
um become a predominantly
African-American college so we got a
college a community a church and the
Carnegie Woodson Library all within a
two and a half mile radius and now this
main artery known as 95th Street we want
to develop that whole
that whole street and not as gentrifying
but it's Renaissance and we want to be
able to create a model to say to
everyone this is what you can do in your
neighborhood this is what you can do in
your community this is how you build
um you know build community so that
children Thrive so people are not
getting shot you this is the long-term
hardcore
that you have to do um
well that's just amazing to hear about
encouraging to hear about I'm having a
little juxtaposition in my mind so just
to give you a little bit Insight earlier
I guess a couple months ago I was
actually out in Tulsa Oklahoma I don't
know if you know but they opened a new
Museum out there on the 100 year
anniversary on the Tulsa Master yeah so
think about everything that happened
there with Black Wall Street everything
that changed and to put that in
juxtaposition with everything you all
are doing
it's just I don't even know if I can put
it into words but just hearing holding
those two I mean we're history nerds
here that's
you know Tulsa is a model but but we're
an Avenue I mean the history of Auburn
Avenue in Atlanta is there are these
streets everywhere in the black
community there I mean if you if you go
to New Orleans if you if you were to go
to Jackson if you went to Memphis uh I
mean every street they were like this
five block stretch minimum five blocks
if I'm not talking about you know little
tiny little stores
I'm talking about like thriving
businesses attorneys doctors restaurants
dry cleaners every kind of business you
could kind of think of in some places
like in Tulsa they had hotels you know I
mean it was it was it was amazing same
thing with on Auburn Avenue in Atlanta
it had this history we want to replicate
that yeah you know that there was a
model that that worked it was the model
that worked and and when you when you
build these institutions and
um you you create the space that allow
people to thrive and we find out that
home ownership
plus jobs
plus churches that are engaged
reduces
violence dramatically then add Gardens
to the uh to to to to the table plus
libraries and schools you then use the
trend goes down even farther
and so that's what we're trying to do
and then it's not it's not rocket
science if you want to change stuff it's
yeah we've been doing it for a long time
we know how to do it we just need that
uh the the the moral courage to be able
to move forward yeah
so well said no I mean just Inspire I
know for a lot of our listeners
especially as we've been hinting at the
fact that this history is not readily
taught many people might be hearing
aspects of this for the first time which
I think is also an important and huge
step obviously you all have done a
wonderful job of that already in your
community but as much as this can be
modeled and expanded I think is so
important so again you know it's just
really encouraging to hear about all
that you're doing in the midst
in the midst of everything even as you
opened up this conversation in the midst
of everything you're even experiencing
at in your pastoral role day to day so I
mean to me it's just deeply encouraging
to know what you all are about makes me
want to swing by at some point and just
to get even the first thing or get
connected with some of those those uh
those doctors those women black women
who are running things and doing so so
brilliantly it's just yeah I'm
speechless but I'm talking a lot it's a
mixture of the combination of both
coming out at once but any last uh words
that you want to leave are listeners
with in terms of either word of
encouragement or a word of challenge
I would say that you are
birthed and born
with the power of resilience and
resistance
just needs to be nurtured
armed spaces find people
who will pour into you
and when they pour into you
make sure you pour into somebody else
there's nothing more dangerous than a
person who acts like a swamp instead of
acting like a canal
swamps have inlets but no outlet and
that's why swamp smelling things die but
canals are designed to release
for those who are in need
and so be a canal when someone pours
into you
that's all we're called to do
just don't be a swamp that's what
America wants you to be
Amen to that
oh again Dr Moss just appreciate you
taking the time for everything that you
shared all the work that you all are
doing in community together so grateful
and honored to be able to host you here
today thank you again always my pleasure
and we look forward to seeing you in
Chicago sometime yeah that would be
wonderful
foreign
[Music]